10 years ago I was destitute and owed
$15,000 to the IRS I raised my kids by
myself with no contribution from my
ex-wife I followed your teachings and
I'm now debt-free with money in savings
and Investments I'm retired and living
very frugally but I'm terrified of being
destitute again my weekly grocery budget
is am I reading this right
$35 I don't use the AC in the summer and
won't turn on the heat in the winter
this is from Billy in
Indiana uh he turns it on when it gets
below freezing yikes I've taken all the
light bulbs but one out of all the
fixtures in the house I take three
minute showers and haven't eaten out in
two years how do I live without my
phobia of being broke again I mean this
is as much emotional relational as it is
financial I do and I think therapy I
think this is some I think I would get
some therapy on this to be able to
create a narrative that is in opposition
to the voice of fear